mark ballas made his broadway debut and
soon he will be a married man this is a
dream come true mark opened up to ET
about how he's balancing his new role as
Jersey Boys final guy to play Frankie
Valli wedding planning with Beyonce bc
Jean well she's been out here with me
and she just flew back yesterday to go
do like final details of the wedding so
yeah I've been getting texts and
pictures today I got texts of bobble
heads all kinds of stuff they're looking
at like the tablecloths and the settings
and the plates and dishes and the
cutlery and what cocktails were having
it should be facetiming me and probably
it's amazing you know this is an amazing
time right now in our line between
getting to star on Broadway which has
been a dream of mine for years and now
planning the wedding at the same time
which is coming up it's coming up really
quick so it's great I'm I I try not to
get overwhelmed I try not to think too
far ahead I just take each day as it
comes and I'm just less than are the
dancing with the stars pro stayed
tight-lipped about his bachelor party
plans but revealed who his right-hand
man will be for his big day knowing
Derek it'll be it'll be Derek throws a
good party you know but he yeah he's the
best man and you know we've been kind of
talking I tried on his suit the other
day and sent him a picture using I love
them so he said he'll get it tailored
and everything
you